text embeddings and semantic search
in this video we'll explore how
transformer models represent text as
embedding vectors and how these vectors
can be used to find similar documents in
a corpus
text embeddings are just a fancy way of
saying that we can represent text as an
array of numbers called a vector
to create these embeddings we usually
use an encoder-based model like bert
in this example you can see how we feed
three sentences to the encoder and get
three vectors as the output
reading the text we can see that walking
the dog seems to be most similar to
walking the cat but let's see if we can
actually quantify this
the trick to do the comparison is to
compute a similarity metric between each
pair of embedding vectors
these vectors usually live in a very
high dimensional space so a similarity
matrix can be anything that measures
some sort of distance between vectors
one very popular metric is cosine
similarity which uses the angle between
two vectors to measure how close they
are
in this example our embedding vectors
live in 3d and we can see that the
orange and grey vectors are close to
each other and have a smaller angle
now one problem we have to deal with is
that transformer models like bert will
actually return one embedding vector per
token
for example in the sentence i took my
dog for a walk we can expect several
embedding vectors one for each word
for example here we see that the output
of our model has produced nine embedding
vectors per sentence and each vector has
384 dimensions
but what we really want is a single
embedding vector for each sentence
to deal with this we can use a technique
called pooling
the simplest pulling method is just to
take the token embedding of the special
cls token
alternatively we can average the token
embeddings which is called mean pooling
and this is what we do here
with mean pooling the only thing we need
to make sure is that we don't include
the padding tokens in the average which
is why you can see the attention mask
being used here
this gives us a 384 dimensional vector
for each sentence which is exactly what
we want
once we have our sentence embeddings we
can compute the cosine similarity for
each pair of vectors
in this example we use the function from
psychic learn and you can see that the
sentence i took my dog for a walk has
indeed a strong overlap with i took my
cat for a walk hooray we've done it
we can actually take this idea one step
further by comparing the similarity
between a question and a corpus of
documents
for example suppose we embed every post
in the hugging face forums we can then
ask a question embed it and check which
forum posts are most similar
this process is often called semantic
search because it allows us to compare
queries with context
to create a semantic search engine is
actually quite simple in the datasets
library
first we need to embed all the documents
and in this example we take a small
sample from the squad data set and apply
the same embedding logic as before
this gives us a new column called
embeddings which stores the embeddings
of every passage
once we have our embeddings we need a
way to find nearest neighbors for a
query
the datasets library provides a special
object called feis which allows you to
quickly compare embedding vectors
so we add the feis index
embedded question and voila we've now
found the three most similar articles
which might store the answer